this episode is brought to you by
upstart hey wisecrack Jared again today
we're returning to the underwater city
of Rapture to talk about one of the most
widely discussed video game franchises
in recent memory Bioshock of course
longtime viewers will remember that we
covered the philosophy of Bioshock 1 and
BioShock Infinite in the first-ever
wisecrack edition over 4 years ago but
you guys were pretty quick to point out
that we made a purposeful but glaring
omission in that video so today we're
finally gonna go back and address the
often forgotten frequently maligned
middle child of the Bioshock franchise
Bioshock 2 at the time of its released
Bioshock 2 was noted for lacking the
involvement of the series creator Ian
Levine in a 2010 interview Levine said
that he and his team at irrational games
passed on developing the sequel because
they wanted to avoid repeating
themselves we're always trying to
challenge ourselves we felt we had said
what we wanted to say about rapture
about those kinds of environments and
that kind of feel despite this
intimation from Levine that Bioshock 2
is a bit of a rehash of the original
there's still a contingent of fans out
there who remain steadfast in their
belief that this is a great game
praising it for its improved mechanics
and the spin it puts on the themes of
Bioshock 1 so now that we've had nearly
a decade of distance from this
potentially disappointing sequel let's
revisit Bioshock 2 and evaluate whether
it was as successful as some people seem
to think whether reach the same
intellectual heights as the franchise's
first installment whether it's deep or
dumb welcome this wisecrack addition on
Bioshock 2 and as always spoilers ahead
but before we get to it I want to give a
shout out to our sponsors over at
upstart they are the leading marketplace
for providing personal loans if you have
a history of credit card debt getting
into debt is really easy and getting out
is hard especially if your FICO score
isn't great rather than focusing only on
your FICO score upstart rewards you
based on your education and job history
in the form of a smarter interest rate
they also make it fast simple and easy
to check your rate in just a few minutes
without affecting your credit score when
a loan is approved most people get funds
the very next day over 200,000 people
have used up star
to pay off credit cards student loans
from their wedding and make other large
purchases so free yourself from the
burden of high interest credit card debt
by consolidating everything into one
monthly payment with upstart they
believe you are more than just your
credit score see why upstart is ranked
to number one in their category out of
300 other companies on Trustpilot
go to upstart comm slash wisecrack to
find out how low your up start rate is
it takes a few minutes and won't affect
your credit and now back to the show
alright first things first let's do a
little recap in BioShock 2 you play as
Delta a prototype of a big Daddy living
in Andrew Ryan's underwater utopia of
rapture like all big daddies you were
tasked with protecting a little sister
and in the case of Delta that little
sister's name was Eleanor in the game's
prologue Elinor's snatched away from you
by the main antagonist dr. Sophia Lamb
who then uses mind-control to force you
to commit suicide ten years later you
emerge from a vita chamber having been
miraculously resurrected you are then
led through the crumbling city of
Rapture with the aid of Elinor's
telepathic messages and a little help
from some unlikely allies your mission
is to find Eleanor and save her from the
sinisterly soft-spoken Sophia Liam who
by the way is Eleanor's mother pretty
soon you learned that dr. lamb was once
a celebrated psychologist in the heyday
of rapture but after Andrew Ryan's death
in the first Bioshock she transformed
Ryan's failed Objectivist utopia into a
utilitarian collectivist hellscape lamb
has manipulated the poorest most
disenfranchised citizens of rapture
through propaganda and plasmon addiction
to be fiercely loyal to her and the rest
of the rapture family what's more the
family defies Elinor as the first true
utopian because lamb has been pumping
her full of Adam in an attempt to create
a completely selfless completely
altruistic being lambs followers paper
the walls of the city with iconography
representing her in Eleanor that states
we will be reborn
she is our Savior as you make your way
to lambs hideout you encounter her
various allies who you can choose to
kill or spare depending on how generous
you're feeling or how obnoxious their
repeated dialog is okay so dead men tell
no tales right wrong see
with Adam involved every stiffs got a
story there's also a new class of
enemies called Big Sisters which are
more sprightly acrobatic versions of the
Big Daddies that haunt raptures halls
there's still the same Little Sisters
mechanic from the first game which
forces you to choose between saving the
yellow dyed innocents or zapping them
for their precious atom as always the
choices you make determine what kind of
ending you'll get either good bad or
neutral that's pretty much it you
explore the city blasting splicers in an
attempt to rescue your surrogate
daughter from the clutches of her evil
mother but Bioshock has never just been
a first-person shooter the game set
themselves apart from others in the
genre with their rich world building
expertly paced story telling and use of
philosophical text to explore deeper
themes but just how deep can Bioshock 2
get when it's starting at the bottom of
the ocean
part 1 the triumphant lamb we worship in
its depictions of the cultish rapture
family and their fanatical worship of
Sophia and Eleanor Lamb a reason to draw
Bioshock 2 offers some pretty decent
commentary on the dangers of religious
zealotry whereas the first game poked
holes and iran's objectivism by showing
the natural conclusion of a utopia built
on radical self-interest Bioshock 2
flips the script by presenting a
criticism of blind to selfless devotion
to a higher cause while these two
ideologies may seem at odds with one
another especially given that atheism is
a central tenet of Objectivism the game
takes great pains to show that they
might have more in common than one might
think
the people of rapture lost and
leaderless following the civil war
between Ryan and Fontaine and the death
of both characters at the end of
Bioshock 1 our seduced by lambs
philosophy and begin joining the rapture
family in droves a skilled psychologist
plays into their anger at the system
that failed them and promises them
something greater through these new
beliefs these people many of whom
struggled to feed themselves in Ryan's
utopia are now willing to throw their
lives away at Lambs word we've seen this
kind of gsella tree throughout history
both religiously and politically as
people have thrown away their lives or
political freedoms in the name of a
higher cause Lambs targeting of the most
poverty stricken members of the
population is more of a direct allusion
to early Christianity which flourished
in the Roman Empire because of the
church leaders willingness to preach to
and incorporate the lowest members of
society the fact that the word lamb is
often used to refer to Jesus Christ is
no more an accident than Andrew Ryan's
name being a clumsy anagram of ein R and
this mirroring of religious methodology
is plainly obvious in the character
father Simon Wales once a downtrodden
citizen of raptures poorest neighborhood
Wales is energized by lambs philosophy
and converts it into simple religious
doctrine that even the most Adam
corrupted splicer can understand the
senseless death of Wales and his many
followers underscores the danger posed
by a complete surrender of the self this
is the antithesis of the first games
message which focus on the danger of
complete and total self-interest
Bioshock 2's argument appears to be that
things on the flipside can be just as
bad much like how the terror universe
sequence in BioShock Infinite depicts
the populist Vox Populi freedom fighters
ruling over Columbia with the same
authoritarian violence as Comstock it's
a cynical take to say the least but at
least it's coherent and a good reminder
to occasionally criticize your own
actions instead of
giving yourself over to blind faith for
that reason we're gonna give this aspect
of the game a deep ok so bioshock 2 does
a nice job criticizing overzealous
devotion to lambs philosophy but what
exactly is her philosophy part two when
the greater good goes bad in the same
way that Andrew Ryan was a physical
embodiment of iron Rams Objectivist
philosophy Sophia lamb is an
amalgamation of a number of different
utilitarian thinkers most notably John
Stuart Mill mill was a British
philosopher born in 1806 who was seen by
many as the direct successor to Jeremy
Bentham the father of utilitarian ethics
in his book aptly titled utilitarianism
Mill provides a summary explanation and
defense of his philosophy founded on the
greatest happiness principle which
states that actions are right in
proportion as they tend to promote
happiness wrong as they tend to produce
the reverse of happiness in other words
what is good is what creates the most
happiness for the most people this brand
of morality is under the umbrella of
consequentialist ethics meaning that
when it comes to determining the
morality of an action the ends justify
the means
Rand's version of rational egoism is
also a consequentialist theory but where
Rand believes
each person should act in their own
self-interest for their own happiness
utilitarians favor lessening the focus
on the self and prioritizing the
happiness of everyone instead this line
of thinking would certainly appeal to
someone like Sophia Lamb who has
convinced herself that turning Eleanor
into an egoless Adam repository would be
the ultimate dissolution of the self and
usher in a new utopia and like any good
consequentialist she seems hell-bent on
accomplishing this goal by any means
necessary
the city is nothing rapture must die so
that Elinor may rise from its body all
her actions throughout the game the
confinement of Elinor the kidnapping of
young girls to make into little sisters
the careless manipulation of splicers
are all done in the name of a future
greater good still it's pretty hard to
argue that lambs actions are promoting
happiness or hindering suffering across
the board throughout your entire stay in
the city of Rapture the only person who
seems to be having a good
is that damn clown and if lamb is really
meant to be a student of Mills
philosophy she maybe should have paid a
little closer attention to the text in
his essay on Liberty mill very clearly
states that the soul end for which
mankind are warranted individually or
collectively in interfering with the
liberty of action of any of their number
is self-protection that the only purpose
for which power can be rightfully
exercised over any member of a civilized
community against his will is to prevent
harm to others
basically the ends don't justify the
means if it requires hurting people
practically the entire action of the
game is set around members of lambs
collective attempting to do harm to
Delta through a series of surprise
attacks the argument could be made that
by attempting to free Eleonora Delta is
doing harm to the rapture family and
they're only acting in self-defense but
that argument is about as airtight as
Dionysius Park ultimately lamb talks a
big game about her utilitarian
collectivist beliefs but falls well
short of actually being a utilitarian
her book unity and metamorphosis
excerpts of which are heard throughout
the game asserts the evolution of the
human race is leading to a death of the
South a complete loss of ego and
subsequently the end of tyranny but in
practice lamb is acting like a selfish
tyrant she performs dangerous
experiments on her own daughter I'm
alive I've seen enough to be curious
about the son she turns young girls and
men into little sisters and Big Daddies
against their will she kills anybody who
attempts to leave rapture all so she can
be proven right in her beliefs and
creates some hypothesized atom fueled
God she would consider this to be the
ultimate death of the self but for
anyone besides her there doesn't seem to
be much utility in it in the character
of dr. Sophie lamb Bioshock 2 attempted
to create a philosophical villain that
believed in everything Andrew Ryan
despised and still managed to be evil
unfortunately it's difficult to make a
truly selfless charitable collectivist
perform acts of villainy without seeming
incoherent
if their philosophy is about
selflessness but they're on some kind of
egotistical power trip then you can see
how that might criticize the power trip
more than the philosophy itself so we're
gonna have to give this section a dumb
however if you're going to argue that
the game is less criticizing the actual
philosophy like in BioShock one and more
criticizing how these philosophies are
poorly implemented by tyrants we could
see how one might call it deep
unfortunately for Sophia lamb the
inconsistency between her beliefs and
actions is only one of her problems the
other is where she lives
part three haven't we been here before
by placing the events of Bioshock 2 in
the same location as Bioshock 1 the
philosophy and actions of people like
Sophia lamb are immediately placed in
the context of Ryan's world maybe
playing as a different character but the
story is a continuation of the first
game in every sense of the word so much
so that it's difficult to avoid picking
up audio Diaries from familiar old
characters filling in unnecessary plot
points the game is riddled with
superfluous winks and nods to stuff from
Bioshock 1 making this feel more like
DLC than a sequel and because of this
the villains of Bioshock 2 are never
given a chance to breathe in the first
Bioshock we're given glimpses of Ryan's
utopia at its peak we're shown the
potential of his lofty dream which is
what makes the crumbly reality of it hit
that much harder the criticism of
Objectivism is more biting because we
see the fallout from these beliefs in
Bioshock 2 the new utopia never gets off
the ground because things have already
gone to hell lamb and her followers are
attempting to rise from the ashes but
they can't shake off Ryan's ghost lamb
presented her philosophy as an
alternative to Ryan's
but her utilitarianism or a narco
collectivism or whatever you want to
call it never manifest it in the same
way that Ryan's magical City at the
bottom of the ocean did and in the end
the result was the same anyway in
fighting destruction death in a one-way
trip in a bathysphere to the
surface it's hard to effectively poke
holes in a new ideology when the player
is still inhabiting a world ruined by
the previous one and when the presence
of said ideology is only in the
antagonist words not in her actions
Bioshock is a franchise is about how the
lofty ambitions of men are doomed to
fail because of inherent personal flaws
but in Bioshock 2 those lofty ambitions
amount to some vague talk about how a
young woman is going to be turned into a
utopia if I'm right Ella knows momma's
use an atom to force all raptures minds
and memories into the poor girl lamb
reckons it'll make that child a saint so
you're left trudging through a city
you've already trudged through all for
the sake of saving your daughter who
isn't even really your daughter oddly
enough that's also one of the best
things you can say about Bioshock 2 it's
trying to tell a personal emotional
story a story about a Big Daddy and a
little sister a story that's either
about redemption or loss of innocence
depending on how you play for some
people that's enough and for that reason
we'll settle on giving Bioshock 2 a
rating of kinda deep sure the criticism
of the philosophical ideologies is
pretty toothless but it has some
interesting things to say about the
inherent value of the self and the power
of caring about someone rather than the
vague notion of everyone but what do you
guys think is Bioshock 2 a fitting
sequel to one of the most revered games
of all time let us know what you think
in the comments thanks to all our
patrons who support the channel and our
podcasts don't forget to hit that
subscribe button and before you go I
want to give another shout-out to
upstart they reward you based on your
education and job history in the form of
a smarter interest rate see why upstart
is ranked number one in their category
of over 300 businesses on Trustpilot go
to upstart comm slash wisecrack to find
out how low your upstart rate is
checking your rate only takes a few
minutes and it won't affect your credit
thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]